esta decisión tiene profundas
connotaciones políticas enfrentará una
vez más a Londres y edimburgo ahora no
solamente por la posibilidad de un
segundo referéndum de Independencia sino
por la legitimidad democrática que tiene
el parlamento escocés Esa es la primera
vez que Londres el gobierno central
bloquea una ley aprobada por el
parlamento de Escocia desde que fue
creado en 1999 según el gobierno
británico esta ley escocesa creaba
conflicto con otras leyes de equidad en
todo el Reino Unido la ministra
principal escocesa al repudiar esta
decisión de Londres dijo que es un
ataque frontal al parlamento escocés que
puede tomar y Puede crear sus propias
leyes y anunció que dará la pelea legal
esta ley que fue aprobada a finales de
2022 hacía más fácil el cambio legal de
género y por ejemplo
de 18 a 16 años la edad para cambiar
legalmente de género y eliminaba para
ello un diagnóstico médico de disforia
de género